un rapporteur
bien chers collègues je vous propose que
le début de son
notre audition nous recevons aujourd'hui
le général Bruno jokers qui est major
général de la gendarmerie nationale sur
l'organisation de la police judiciaire
cela peut vous paraître étonnant que
nous ayons un gendarme ou des plutôt la
particularité de notre mission en
général c'est nos deux rapporteurs sont
ici Monsieur Durin et Madame belluroux
la commission des lois a décidé de
mettre en place une mission
d'information sur le projet de réforme
du gouvernement de l'organisation de la
police nationale
avec une volonté de départementaliser
celle-ci
et la question est apparue au grand
public aujourd'hui
de l'avenir de la police judiciaire avec
un certain nombre de contestations qui
se sont manifestés que ce soit de
policiers eux-mêmes voire même du monde
judiciaire pour dire que ce ne serait
pas forcément une bonne chose
nous sommes pas au stade des conclusions
du travail que nous avons engagé
naturellement et qu'engager nos
rapporteurs tout particulièrement mais
nous savons que l'organisation de la
gendarmerie est intéressante de ce point
de vue là la fois départementale et à la
fois avec des sections de recherche qui
sont un peu plus indépendantes et donc
tout l'intérêt de votre audition ce
n'est pas un piège je le redis c'est de
comprendre comment vous fonctionnez et
comment fonctionne la gendarmerie
nationale en la matière de façon à
nourrir
évidemment la réflexion de la commission
des lois et singulièrement de l'odeur
rapporteurs voilà j'ai déjà été beaucoup
trop long peut-être avant de vous dire
que nous sommes effectivement retransmis
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
ce qui explique pour les collègues que
les rideaux soient baissés pour qu'on
ait une meilleure image et que voilà les
choses se passent bien
en général vous avez la parole
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs mesdames messieurs je suis
très honoré d'être auditionné ce soir
dans le cas de cette mission
d'information sur la réforme de la
police judiciaire dans le contexte de la
création des directions départementales
de la police nationale je comprends
cette audition comme une marque
d'intérêt et d'attention envers la
gendarmerie nationale et son
organisation sur un sujet fondamental
parce que au bout de la police
judiciaire il y a avant tout des
victimes qui sont en attente de
réparation mon propos liminaire vise à
expliquer notre organisation et notre
fonctionnement et non pas à porter un
jugement sur une réforme qui concerne la
police nationale
la police judiciaire c'est le fait de
constater des infractions dans
rassembler les preuves et dans déférer
les auteurs sous la direction des
magistrats je m'exprimerai donc avec
humilité la gendarmerie nationale ne
fait pas de la police judiciaire dans
son coin et pour son compte elle fait de
la police judiciaire sous la direction
le contrôle et la surveillance des
magistrats et je vous demande d'avoir
cela en permanence dans à l'esprit en
m'écoutant et puis nous le faisons
également sous le regard évidemment de
la population dans ce propos liminaire
je voudrais exposer quatre points le
premier c'est d'où vient notre
organisation le second le deuxième c'est
est-ce que cette organisation fonctionne
le troisième point c'est
comment concevons nous l'exercice de la
police judiciaire en gendarmerie et
enfin mon dernier mon dernier point
traitera de nos relations dans le cas de
la police judiciaire avec les avec nos
autorités d'emploi
premier premier point notre organisation
l'organisation de la police de la
gendarmerie nationale en matière de
police judiciaire je rappelle que nous
avons une compétence nationale
compétences nationales qui provient du
fait que le magistrat par l'article 12-1
du code de procédure pénale à le libre
choix du service qui le saisit donc
compétences nationales mais évidemment
dans les critères d'attribution et de
saisines des services que ce soit des
services de police nationale de
gendarmerie nationale le lieu de
commission de l'infraction à une
importance particulière
je reviens donc la zone de gendarmerie
nationale cette zone de gendarmerie que
vous connaissez bien ce sont des espaces
95 96% du territoire national c'est de
la population de plus en plus 52% de la
population et puis ce sont des flux de
population des flux l'été l'hiver donc
on gère on gère des mouvements ce qui
signifie que la police judiciaire et la
délinquance en zone de gendarmerie c'est
de la délinquance souvent itinérante qui
se déplace parce que notre population
elle-même se déplace pour travailler ou
pour
le se déplacer sur le territoire c'est
une police judiciaire de proximité parce
que nous agissons dans des territoires
où la population est habituée à de la
proximité si vous avez une affaire
judiciaire dans une ville moyenne de
province ou dans ou dans un village où
vous attendez à ce qui est une relation
de proximité du service de sécurité vous
attendez pas à voir arriver des gens
vous avez jamais vu
et ce qui veut dire que
dans on va dire dans l'ADN de la
gendarmerie il y a l'idée que la police
judiciaire est associée à un ancrage
local et que les meilleurs enquêteurs
sont ceux qui sont le mieux ancrés dans
la population parce qu'ils ont leur
enseignement parce qu'ils ont la
compréhension des choses et parce qu'on
leur parlera plus facilement ce qui veut
dire et je le répéterai à plusieurs
reprises que nous n'avons pas une police
judiciaire haut du spectre qui viendrait
prendre des affaires au niveau des
unités territoriales nous avons des
unités ou du spread ou du spectre qui
viennent appuyer les unités
territoriales mais on a toujours besoin
du gendarme local et du gendarme de
brigade quel que soit la sensibilité de
l'affaire parce qu'il agit dans un
territoire et avec une population qu'il
connaît
ça donc conduit la gendarmerie à adopté
quelques quelques principes qui se sont
apposés au fur et à mesure de notre
histoire d'abord la polyvalence du
gendarme le gendarme de brigade est tout
gendarme de brigade est un enquêteur
alors il est agent de police judiciaire
officier de police judiciaire selon
qu'il a qu'il a passé l'examen ou non
mais tout gendarmes est un enquêteur de
la même manière que tout gendarme peut
effectuer une patrouille de nuit que
tout gendarme peut être amené à
constater une infraction à la police sur
la route etc le fonctionnement en silo
serait inadapté à la gendarmerie on
imagine pas une brigade où on soit un
moment donné en mesure de dire bah
écoutez cette affaire on peut pas la
traiter parce que tous nos enquêteurs
sont pris on peut pas recevoir votre
plainte parce que on a personne qui est
qualifié pour etc nous avons des gens
qui sont qui sont polyvalents
le socle c'est la brigade territoriale
tout doit converger vers elle parce que
c'est elle qui est au contact de la
population et sur ce le socle de cette
brigade nous construisons des unités
judiciaires qui sont elles spécialisées
et qui viennent en appui qui sont pas
autonome qui ne sont pas indépendantes
qui viennent en appui des capacités
offertes par les brigades territoires
ces unités ce sont lesquelles ce sont
les brigades de recherche qui agissent
qui ont une compétence départementale
qui sont en fait on se calme sur la
carte judiciaire et sur les et sur les
tribunaux judiciaires la vraie des
brigades de recherche ce sont un tout
petit peu moins de 3000 enquêteurs ce
sont les sections de recherche que vous
avez mentionnées monsieur le Président
donc 1597 gendarmes 43 sections de
recherche dont la compétence est au
niveau des cours d'appel c'est pour
cette raison qu'elles ont été rattachées
organiquement aux commandants de région
parce que les régions étaient pour nous
le dimensionnement de la maille la plus
proche de celle des cours d'appel nous
avons des appuies régionaux en matière
d'organisation surveillance et notamment
de cyber et des appuis nationaux donc
c'est la criminalistique le pot
judiciaire à Pontoise c'est l'office de
la délinquance itinéraire c'est l'office
de l'environnement et de la santé
publique le principe est un principe
tout à fait militaire c'est le principe
de Foch l'économie des forces
c'est-à-dire que ce qui est rare en fait
on le concentre au niveau
régional ou au niveau national pour
pouvoir le projeter au plus près du
terrain et l'avoir là où on en a besoin
la saisine donc les relations que les
magistrats sont organisées sur la base
un protocole qui date de 2006 et qui et
qui garde toute sa toute sa valeur qui
est un protocole très simple mais qui
explique le niveau de chacune des unités
de gendarmerie et les modalités de ces
îles le magistrat de saisir soit un
commandant de formation il peut saisir
un commandant de groupement au niveau
départemental à commander région il peut
saisir le directeur de la gendarmerie
nationale qui est également au PJ ou
alors il saisit directement une unité
une section de recherche une une brigade
de recherche sur une enquête qu'il
souhaite plus particulièrement leur
confier en raison des compétences
spécifiques qui sont les leurs
il n'y a pas d'attribution automatique
en fonction
de d'un domaine de délinquance il n'y a
pas d'attribution automatique en fait il
y a un principe de subsidiarité c'est à
dire que la au niveau du terrain la
brigade territoriale traite ce qu'elle
peut traiter en fonction de ses
effectifs de ses capacités quand elle
est dépassée à ce moment-là la brigade
de recherche doit venir l'appuyer et si
la brigade de recherche ne suffit pas
c'est la section de recherche qui doit
qui doit s'investir
je reviens sur le cette séparation qu'on
utilise assez souvent que les médias
utilisent en matière de petite moyenne
et grande délinquance pour vous dire que
je comprends qu'on utilise cette
séparation elle est commode mais elle
n'est pas elle n'explique pas tout de la
police judiciaire pourquoi parce que
vous avez évidemment des phénomènes de
délinquance série réel ou de trafic de
déchets qui à la base peuvent pré
isolément être des faits dit de petites
moyennes délinquance mais qui à partir
du moment où il correspondent à des
réseaux organisés deviennent de la
grande délinquance et que seuls des
unités spécialisées peuvent traiter des
cambriolages si vous en avez un c'est
peut-être de la petite ou de la moyenne
délinquance sauf pour la victime mais
quand vous en avez 15 30 ou 40 la
brigade ne peut plus traiter vous êtes
donc obligé d'engager votre brigade de
recherche et votre section de recherche
et nos sections de recherche travaillent
sur les cambriolages et elle travaille
sur de la délinquance serielle et
heureusement parce que au bout du compte
ce qui compte c'est quand même la
tranquillité de la population la
protection des personnes et des biens
donc pour nous dire qu'une section de
recherche de travaillerait pas sur des
cambriolages ce serait tout simplement
une hérésie de la même manière des
déchets des décharges sauvages ça peut
être pris pour étant de la petite ou de
la moyenne délinquance sauf que si ce
sont des trafics de déchets ça devient
aussi de la criminalité organisée les
vols dans les transports quand vous avez
une personne qui se fait voler son
portable c'est peut-être de la petite ou
d'un moyen délinquance mais si c'est un
réseau organisé qui utilise des mineurs
etc ça devient de la criminalité
organisée et c'est des unités ou du
spectre qui doivent travailler dessus il
y a donc une complémentarité des moyens
et une souplesse dans le dispositif et
d'ailleurs nous travaillons très souvent
en cellule d'en qui associe le gendarme
de brigade territoriale un gendarme de
Brigade de Recherche et un gendarme de
Section de Recherche et ils vont
travailler ensemble sur un fait
particulier qui peut être un homicide ou
sur un phénomène criminel parce que on a
besoin d'unir les forces mais qu'on a
toujours besoin et de l'ancrage local du
gendarme de brigade et de l'unité
spécialisée et je voudrais le sur ce sur
ce point pour bien me faire comprendre
nous restons en gendarmerie attaché au
principe de la théorie du carreau cassé
je pense que
tous vous l'avez vous l'envir en tête
mais ces théories du carreau cassé elle
est toujours pour nous pertinente quand
on dit que si vous avez un carreau cassé
sur un bâtiment et que vous laissez le
carreau casser
vous encouragez en fait à un moment
donné vous n'aurez que des carreaux
cassées sur ce bâtiment parce que vous
donnerez le sentiment que ce bâtiment
n'a pas n'appartient à personne et vous
donnerez le sentiment qu'il y a une
impunité pour celui qui casse le carreau
ce qui veut dire qu'à un moment donné ce
n'est pas que la délinquance qui crée le
sentiment d'insécurité c'est aussi le
sentiment d'insécurité qui encourage la
délinquance il est donc tout à fait
artificiel de séparer d'un côté
l'exercice de la police judiciaire et de
l'autre côté celui de la prévention et
la sécurité publique les deux marchent
de pair dans une société bien ordonnée
deuxième point est-ce que notre
organisation fonctionne
bon la police judiciaire c'est de
l'ordre de 40% de l'activité de la
gendarmerie c'est donc quelque chose de
de fondamental il y a même des endroits
des compagnies où on dépasse les 50%.
alors nos
notre bilan actuel sur 2021 donc nous
avons nous représentons 35 %
des crimes et des lits constatées dans
notre dans notre pays
nous notre activité nous permet donc de
poursuivre 42% des mises en cause dans
notre pays donc bonne proportion presque
la moitié des mises en cause par la
police judiciaire sont le fait d'unité
de gendarmerie nous avons un taux
d'élucination qui est de
46,8%. donc il reste tout à fait
respectable et qui est de 3 points et
demi supérieur à celui qu'il était il y
a 5 ans
nous élucidons huit violences huit
comment dire violent sur personne sur
dix huit homicides sur 10 également 75%
des violences sexuelles 35% des vols à
marée nous élucidons 13,8% des
cambriolages d'habitation c'est pas
suffisant mais c'est la moyenne des
services européens je pense d'ailleurs
que le c'est certainement le critère le
plus intéressant regardez sur une force
de sécurité c'est combien quel est son
taux du lucidation en matière de
cambriolage parce que c'est là sur la
délinquance sérieuse souvent qui dès le
plus dur de travailler et puis ça ce
sont des chiffres mais il y a aussi les
virages que nous avons pris et je crois
que ces dernières années la police
judiciaire en gendarmerie a été capable
de prendre le virage du cyber avec la
création du commandement cyber et le
quelques enquêtes qui ont fait notre
réputation au niveau européen voire
mondial je pense notamment à
nous prenons le virage de
l'environnement alors on travaillait sur
l'environnement on avait des référents
environnement mais on va beaucoup plus
structurer notre action l'organiser avec
la proposition d'un commandement de la
gendarmerie verte toute la protection de
l'environnement et puis nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur l'amélioration du
traitement des violences intrafamilales
et conjugales et on sait que il y avait
besoin sans aucun doute de renforcer nos
procédures et de et d'y mettre d'y
mettre un effort nous ne subissons pas
de retard majeur en matière de procédure
puisque nous avons moins de 5% de nos
procédures qui ont plus d'un an et pour
certaines
elles étaient vouées à avoir plus d'un
an parce que ce sont des enquêtes de
longue haleine etc ou qui a simplement
des des un certain nombre de choses à
faire nous avons moins de procédures en
retard aujourd'hui que nous n'en avions
en 2015 et puis en matière d'attrait
pour la police judiciaire il n'y a pas
de infection pour la police judiciaire
en gendarmerie au contraire puisque nous
avions en 2021 3423 candidats pour
l'examen technique d'officier de police
judiciaire alors que nous en avions 3001
en 2020 donc belle j'irai une belle Abel
équilibre cette année nous avons 68% de
taux de réussite à l'examen d'officiers
de police judiciaire en gendarmerie ce
qui veut dire que on n'est pas du tout
si vous me pardonnez l'expression en
train de racler des fonds tiroirs pour
recruter des OPJ on a un examen qui
conserve toute sa pertinence
troisième point les principes de
l'exercice de la police judiciaire en
gendarmerie quelques points qui sont
pour nous très simples d'abord je l'ai
dit nous exerçons la police judiciaire
sous la direction sous le contrôle et
sur la sous la surveillance des
magistrats ce qui veut dire que dans le
rapport que nous avons avec les
magistrats je pense qu'il faut
distinguer deux choses les magistrats
dirigent des enquêteurs dans le cas des
investigations il leur donne des
directives pour les militaires que nous
sommes des ordres
donc il dirige les enquêteurs et ensuite
ils ont un rapport de chef de service à
chef de service avec les commandements
territoriaux puisque les commandements
thermiques historiaux fournissent les
effectifs et fournissent les moyens il y
a donc deux choses différentes données
des directives et des instructions dans
le cadre d'une enquête ces diriger un
enquêteur et ça c'est ce que la loi
confie et au magistrat et puis avoir
pour interlocuteur un patron territorial
qui a dans sa main des moyens de la
gendarmerie pour dire de lui ce qu'on
attend en terme d'effectif de moyens
d'efforts etc c'est autre chose quand on
organise par exemple la procédure pénale
numérique sur un département évidemment
c'est un dialogue qui se fait de chef HF
parce que il faut s'y préparer il faut
s'organiser et il faut se coordonner
enfin nous avons un creuset pour tout
gendarme qui est la brigade toujours en
arbre départementale qui est la brigade
territoriale un gendarme d'unité de
recherche a commencé sa carrière en
brigade territoriale il sait ce que
c'est et parce que il s'est fait
remarquer pour son appétence pour la
police judiciaire il va évoluer faire
une brigade de recherche sur une section
de recherche mais à un moment ou un
autre tout le monde est passé par le
même endroit et tout le monde appartient
à la même maison et tout le monde porte
le même maillot
et ce système doit nous permettre de
concilier la polyvalence que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure mais qui a
évidemment ses limites si vous
travaillez en cyber vous avez besoin
d'experts en matière de
de crypto monnaie par exemple vous allez
pas prendre quelqu'un qui a une
expertise pour lui dire un moment donné
tu vas revenir faire un travail de
généraliste si vous avez une compétence
rare bien évidemment vous allez la
conserver mais au départ tout le monde
est passé par le même endroit et tout le
monde à la même compréhension du métier
mon quatrième et dernier point c'est je
voudrais brosser simplement les
relations dans le cas de la police
judiciaire que nous pouvons entretenir
avec nos autorités hiérarchiques d'abord
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je ne
reconnais pas une séparation entre la
sécurité publique et la police
judiciaire il y en a une qui prévient la
Commission des infractions sécurité
publique c'est son travail mais la
police judiciaire a le même objectif
puisque elle a pour but d'empêcher la
réitération des faits en interpellant
des auteurs donc évidemment les deux les
deux sont liés et il faut donc nos chefs
territoriaux s'intéressent à la police
judiciaire ce serait une faute pour un
commandant de compagnie ou un commandant
de groupement que de ne pas s'intéresser
à la police judiciaire et de ne pas
donner à ces enquêteurs les moyens de
travailler c'est le point suivant je
voulais aborder
pour moi il est également
anormal
d'opposer l'enquêteur et le chef
territorial parce que le chef
territorial est là pour aider
l'enquêteur il est là pour lui donner
des moyens il est là pour lui donner du
temps il est là pour donner des
effectifs lorsqu'ils le font et il est
là parfois aussi pour le protéger parce
que parfois l'enquêteur va être sur une
enquête sensible va être dans des
situations qui sont compliquées et il a
aussi besoin de sa hiérarchie pour
qu'elle puisse le conseiller d'appuyer
le suivre l'accompagner rien de pire
qu'un enquêteur qui serait seul dans des
affaires particulièrement sensibles
médiatisés ou avec une forte une forte
pression
un point enfin sur le le secret
professionnel et sur le secret de
l'enquête donc on est dans l'article 11
qui concerne toute personne qui qui
concourt qui concourt à la procédure
alors l'enquêteur évidemment est soumis
à ce secret de l'enquête dès lors qu'il
investit sous la direction des
magistrats est-ce qu'il tient à former
sa hiérarchie oui il tient à former sa
hiérarchie et heureusement parce que si
on avait une hiérarchie qui était
aveugle d'un point de vue de police
judiciaire comment voulez-vous concevoir
une action sur un territoire qui puisse
aider à prévenir la délinquance
simplement et évidemment là où il y a
des comment dire des limites c'est que
d'abord de quoi parle-t-on avec les
enquêteurs le l'objet d'un commandant
Groupon d'un commandant de région c'est
pas de rentrer dans le secret des
enquêtes pour le plaisir de savoir telle
ou telle chose ou d'en savoir plus que
les autres ou alors c'est que on pas mal
sélectionné notre personne le chef
territorial a besoin de savoir là où il
doit engager des moyens il a besoin
d'avoir une action cohérente il a besoin
d'avoir aussi parfois une stratégie
d'enquête si vous êtes face à des délin
cancériel vous avez besoin d'avoir une
stratégie de police judiciaire vous
devez pas prendre l'effet les uns après
les autres et il faut évidemment en
discuter en débattre et vous avez besoin
d'avoir une action qui soit cohérente
entre la police judiciaire et la
sécurité publique et la et la
surveillance générale donc évidemment
les les débats les discussions que nous
avons avec les enquêteurs ça tient pas
tant à l'enquête spécifique que de
savoir si notre action gendarmerie sur
notre territoire en matière de police
judiciaire et cohérente et efficace
vis-à-vis du préfet puisque c'est une
question qui est qui est récurrente et
qui nous est posée d'abord il faut qu'on
ait tous et qu'on reconnaisse que les
choses deviennent plus compliquées
aujourd'hui en raison de la de
l'importance compris les réseaux sociaux
la protection du secret professionnel la
rapidité de l'information la divulgation
des informations à considérablement
évolué avec les réseaux sociaux et
évidemment aujourd'hui la difficulté
c'est que vous allez avoir une affaire
judiciaire qui va très rapidement
devenir un objet de communication par
les réseaux sociaux ce sera un objet de
communication parce que vous aurez
peut-être une des parties qui va
communiquer parce que les journalistes
ont leur propre moyens parce que on
évolue avec toute une désintérêt qui
peuvent être des intérêts associatifs ou
autres il y a un moment donné vont
s'emparer d'une affaire qui est dans une
phase de traitement judiciaire mais qui
devient déjà une affaire publique
donc je crois qu'il faut reconnaître et
d'ailleurs il y avait une mission
parlementaire je crois en 2019 qui avait
profondément travaillé sur le sujet du
secret de l'enquête il faut reconnaître
que aujourd'hui le secret de l'enquête
est peut-être plus compliqué qu'il ne le
fut naguère en raison des réseaux
sociaux et de la rapidité avec laquelle
une affaire judiciaire devient un objet
un objet public alors
vis-à-vis du préfet je crois qu'il y a
deux cas qui sauvent opposition du
magistrat peuvent justifier de le tenir
informé d'une affaire judiciaire c'est
lorsqu'on a des risques
avérés de troubles à l'ordre public et
là la question se pose si vous savez que
vous allez interpeller quelqu'un dans
une cité pour un trafic de stupéfiant
mais que ça risque de générer des
troubles à l'ordre public vous êtes
quand même bien inspiré de proposer à
votre préfet peut-être de solliciter une
force mobile pour que à l'issue des
interpellations on puisse garantir le
calme comment on le fait si on peut pas
tenir informer le préfet on va lui dire
écoutez j'aurais besoin d'une force
mobile mais je peux pas vous dire
pourquoi bon c'est pas c'est pas
raisonnable donc lorsqu'on a des risques
avérés de troubles à l'ordre public oui
il faut qu'il y ait un dialogue qui se
dire qui se qui se fasse et puis il y a
également et malheureusement l'actualité
nous en fournit des exemples toutes les
semaines il y a la propagation
d'information fausse sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment ce sont les fake news
si vous avez la propagation d'une
information fausse vous êtes quand même
bien inspiré de préciser au préfet que
tel ou telle chose n'a pas de n'a pas de
fondement je précise également que dans
la manière de d'informer un enquêteur ou
un commandant territorial qui a un peu
doigté c'est parfaitement le faire en
restant dans les limites et sans mettre
le pied sur le la ligne on a la
possibilité d'anonymiser les choses on a
la possibilité de donner ce dont
l'autorité peut avoir besoin de
connaître sans aller au-delà de ce que
nous de ce que nous permettrait la loi
et puis je rajouterai un troisième cas
qui n'est pas prévu par le par la loi
mais enfin qui s'impose en fait dans la
pratique c'est lorsqu'il y a une
médiatisation imminente lorsque vous
savez que un journaliste va sortir telle
ou telle affaire bon vous pouvez
toujours vous dire bon le préfet la
prendra avec la lecture du journal
demain mais bon c'est quand même
moyennement moyennement
voilà voilà monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les quatre points que
je me proposais de soumettre à votre
attention merci mon général pour cette
présentation et les pressions que vous
avez apportées on va passer aux
questions les rapporteurs ont-ils des
questions madame bellerault
vous dites que dans la gendarmerie il y
a pas de désinfections donc vous
l'expliquez par le fait est-ce que vous
l'expliquez par le fait qu'il y a cette
forme de polyvalence qui on a bien senti
dans la police nationale c'est pas tout
à fait le cas il y a la PJ et puis un
peu le reste des autres services est-ce
que vous vous pensez que c'est parce que
on a bien compris que tout le monde
était passé par la même par la même
école et la même formation mais est-ce
que ça viendrait que laisser de
polyvalence et que
ça ça permet donc de vivre ensemble de
façon un peu différente et vous avez
aussi vous vous mettez en place des
cellules une cellule d'enquête et donc
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
comment vous l'organiser c'est-à-dire
qu'avec une affaire comment vous
l’organiser et
puis voilà et après je laisserai mes
collègues et à six dernières choses
parce que on parle de les magistrats
qu'on a eu l'occasion de dictionner
qu'on auditionnera encore sont encore
sont très inquiets de du fait que la
police judiciaire échapperait que voilà
aujourd'hui vous vous ne vivez pas ça on
essaie de comprendre pourquoi les
magistrats auraient c'est inquiétude
alors si vous ne pouvez pas répondre
pour la police mais pourquoi les
magistrats c'est inquiétude par rapport
à la police nationale PJ et aujourd'hui
elle n'existe pas il y a pas cette
défiance cette inquiétude par rapport à
la gendarmerie et voilà et donc
ça a l'air de marcher donc on comprend
pas forcément ce que les magistrats
peuvent nous dire par rapport à cette
inquiétude donc vous relations à vous
sont sont bien huilés entre guillemets
merci en général pierre-pont Sud il y a
deux autres trois autres collègues qui
sont inscrits
sur le la trait que continue à avoir la
police judiciaire en gendarmerie je
pense que la polyvalence y participe
c'est peut-être pas le seul facteur mais
n'essaye participe parce que si vous
voulez en fait le gendarme va commencer
en brigade et
s'il a un attrait pour la police
judiciaire il aura envie de ils leur ont
envie de continuer donc
je pense que c'est un choix de sa part
de s'engager vers les vers les unités de
recherche et vers le comment dire vers
une voie officier de tous les judiciaire
et moi lorsque j'interroge les
nos officiers de police judiciaire
puisque c'est un peu l'indicateur que
j'avais pris qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
argument on a avant tout
l'attrait pour le judiciaire ça c'est et
le fait d'avoir une forme d'autonomie
aussi dans son travail parce que quand
vous êtes à PJ vous êtes APJ sous la
direction d'un OPJ donc vous avez envie
d'avoir une vous avez envie de pouvoir
travailler sur des enquêtes qui sont
plus plus complexes ça je crois que
c'est le premier ressort le deuxième
ressort c'est que en gendarmerie
départementale pour faire une carrière
de gradé vous devez être au PJ donc le
il y a un lien étroit et d'ailleurs
c'est assez étonnant parce que ça pas
toujours été le cas en fait ce lien le
il commence à se bâtir dans
l'entre-deux-guerres entre la première
et la seconde guerre mondiale donc ça
pas c'est pas depuis la création de la
gendarmerie et mais si vous voulez être
gradé dans une brigade territoriale vous
devez être au PJ donc voilà c'est c'est
deux des raisons je pense qu'il y en a
il y en a beaucoup d'autres mais moi la
réponse au cours de ma carrière qui m'a
été faite le plus souvent par des EPG y
compris par des gendarmes au PG qui ne
voulaient pas faire de carrière de gradé
c'était de dire moi j'ai envie de d'être
plus autonome dans ce que je fais j'ai
envie de faire des enquêtes plus
complexes voilà donc
je pense que c'est ça qui comment dire
qui qui participent et puis il y a aussi
je pense que le travail le travail en
brigade il y a des gens qui sont faits
pour le travail en brigade parce que ils
aiment le contact
régulier avec la population parce qu'ils
aiment cette forme de polyvalence etc et
puis vous en avez d'autres qui
rapidement vont avoir envie de quelque
chose de plus spécialisé de plus ciblé
donc voilà c'est du coup en gendarmerie
on fait un peu la carrière à sa carte en
fonction de ses aptitudes et en fonction
de de comment dire de son envie sur les
cellules d'enquête comment ça se passe
alors c'est là si vous voulez ou je
parlais tout à l'heure du rôle du
magistrat de la direction de la police
judiciaire par le magistrat et du rôle
du chef hiérarchie qui est aussi un
commandant territorial très souvent ça
va être votre commandant de section de
recherche qui va venir vous voir en
disant bon voilà on est saisi de tel
homicide où on est saisi de tels
phénomènes
matériel moi j'ai pas assez de besoins
enfin j'ai pas assez de moyens et il
serait bon aussi qu'on continue à avoir
le soutien de l'abrigatte territoriale
ou de l'accompagner locale et donc vous
allez mettre les différents chefs autour
de la même table vous allez regarder de
quoi il s'agit vous allez y mettre les
moyens et généralement généralement vous
allez avoir la Section de Recherche sur
une direction d'enquête parce que ce
sont nos meilleurs procédures liées mais
vous allez conserver un ou deux
gendarmes de la brigade locale parce
qu'il faut garder l'ancrage local sur
l'affaire voilà et vous allez constituer
un groupe qui va travailler pendant une
période donnée sur un objectif donc ça
c'est la manière et donc on peut
configurer ces cellules d'enquêtes de
manière on peut le faire au niveau
national ça nous arrive aussi
régulièrement de le faire donc c'est un
système qui est très souple et qui doit
être capable de s'adapter à une
délinquance qui elle-même évolue évolue
très comment dire très très vite ensuite
alors sur les relations avec les avec
les magistrats le rôle de la hiérarchie
par rapport
au magistrats je crois que le la
hiérarchie gendarmerie le sait rester à
sa place c'est à dire que le nous la
direction de la police judiciaire par
les magistrats nous pose aucun souci
bien au contraire ça on est là pour
servir les lois c'est c'est notre
comment dire c'est notre rôle et je
pense que du côté des des commandants
territoriaux de la de la gendarmerie ils
savent quel est leur rôle il l'assume
c'est un rôle de moyens de stratégie de
dialogue aussi parfois que les
magistrats lorsqu'on a des difficultés
donc il y a bien une place pour la le
commandement hiérarchique de la
gendarmerie mais les pas question non
plus d'être une autorité concurrente de
celle des magistrats alors un point
particulier qui explique peut-être une
comment dire une différence d'approche
la gendarmerie n'est pas un service
déconcentré de l'État la gendarmerie est
une force armée c'est une force
nationale avec
un directeur général qui est
actuellement en général de gendarmerie
ça pas toujours été le cas dans le dans
le dans le passé mais c'est le cas c'est
le cas aujourd'hui et ce que je veux
dire c'est que par là c'est que
évidemment nous nous sommes sous
l'autorité du préfet en matière de
sécurité publique le préfet fait aussi
une évaluation du commandant de
groupement donc il faudrait pas croire
que d'un côté vous avez les DSP par
exemple qui aurait une grosse pression
du préfet et que le commandement lui
dans le département fait un peu ce qu'il
veut et je dirais moi je suis fort armé
donc j'ai mes distances pas du tout il y
a une évaluation du préfet le préfet et
bien sûr déterminant dans l'appréciation
du du camp regroupement ça n'empêche pas
le commandant de groupement d'être dans
un rôle de chef de devoir l'assumer et
nous ce qu'on apprend dans les écoles à
nos à nos futurs chefs c'est justement
qui sont aussi là pour assumer et être
capable de résister s'il le faut voilà
donc non nous on ressent pas de
difficultés ni vis-à-vis des préfets ni
vis-à-vis des magistrats on est on est à
notre place voilà
merci alors monsieur Durand avec une
question et aussi dans la parole aux
collègues merci monsieur le Président
ravi de revoir le Major Général qui nous
avons déjà travaillé trois questions une
un peu technique qui concerne
l'organisation de la police qui vous
concerne pas mais
il semble que les cycloraires dans la
police nationale contribue à la
désaffection pour beaucoup de policiers
de la ponction d'enquête est-ce que dans
la gendarmerie il y a une difficulté du
même ordre ou est-ce qu'il y a un
continuum de l'organisation qui
faciliterait finalement
ces aspect là deuxième question quelle
est la nature de la coopération
judiciaire entre gendarmerie et police
nationale et est-ce que dans les
territoires d'expérimentation vous avez
pu sentir le cas échéant une
amélioration une plus grande fluidité du
travail judiciaire avec vos collègues
policiers et puis peut-être juste une
remarque je crois que dans ce que vous
avez exposé on comprend bien que d'abord
il y a pas un modèle d'un côté qui
serait départemental et l'autre qui ne
le seraient pas parce que les sections
de recherche et les brigades de
recherche ne sont pas départementale et
je crois que l'organisation du corps
l'institution gendarmerie protège un peu
de cette enfermement départemental mais
c'est juste une remarque terminée
merci beaucoup
alors sur les trois questions alors
cycle horaire n'est pas quelque chose
dans lequel
voilà
dans lequel nous nous reconnaissons
totalement donc il y a un gendarmerie le
principe c'est qu'il y a pas de cycle
horaire alors évidemment il y a des
besoins de repos physiologique que nous
respectons dans toute la mesure du
possible
sauf impératif missionnaire mais il y a
pas de cycle horaire après le si vous
voulez il est vrai que si vous allez
dans une unité de recherche unité de
recherche va vous dire que elle est très
sollicitée que peut-être en brigade
territoriale
l'effectif permet parfois de de mieux
planifier le service alors que l'unité
de recherche vous êtes soumis à l'aléa à
l'événement si vous êtes samedi
minuit et qui a un homicide la section
de recherche va arriver de toute façon
et voilà alors mais je pense que en fait
les choses s'équilibrent c'est-à-dire
que embrigade territoriale peut-être et
je devient peut-être parce que sinon je
me ferais peut-être tuer par Adrien
je pense qu'il y a moyen de s'organiser
pour essayer de mieux planifier le
service en unité de recherche en
revanche en unité de recherche vous avez
je pense moins la pression continue que
vous avez en brigade territoriale ou là
tous les jours vous écopez à peu près le
même le même le même océan quoi donc
finalement quand on regarde unité de
recherche brigade territoriale je pense
que des deux côtés on a des on a des
contraintes et que ce qui fait la
différence c'est la pétanque qu'on a sur
un service plutôt que l'autre en tout
cas il n'y a ni enfin il y a pas de
cycle horaire nichélin ni chez l'autre
donc de ce point de vue là elles sont à
égalité sur la coopération gendarmerie
police moi le retour que j'ai des
commandements outre-mer qui sont
vis-à-vis de de grandir de ddpn c'est
qu'on identifie plus facilement
l'interlocuteur c'est-à-dire qu'on parle
à un acteur locuteur qui a les
différents leviers au lieu de qu'on nous
dise bon pour ça vous allez vous
conduire vous allez vous adresser
à la PAF pour ça vous allez vous
adresser à la PJ pour ça vous irez
plutôt voir la DDSP donc voilà ça
fluidifie et ça permet quand il y a s'il
y a une difficulté de pouvoir l'aborder
de chefs HF voilà c'est pour nous c'est
plutôt un mode de fonctionnement qui
nous comment dire qui nous qui nous qui
nous correspond
sur la question de la département et
région pour nous les enfin il faut pas
opposer l'un et l'autre il faut pas
opposer le département et la région le
département on est encore dans l'échelon
de la proximité on est dans l'échelon de
l'action opérationnelle le corps en
groupement est le chef opérationnel de
la de la gendarmerie et dispose les
brigade de recherche qui ont une
compétence départementale le commandant
de région alors d'abord il y a des
commandes région qui sont aussi
commandant de groupement donc
ce qu'il faut préciser la moitié en fait
puisque sur les 13 vous enlevez les
commandants de région zonal qui eux ne
sont pas en groupement mais dans les
régions dites nonales il est également
commandant de groupement à Dijon le camp
de région est aussi le commandant de de
groupement de la comment dire de la Côte
d'Or donc là aussi on pourrait nous dire
après tout à un moment donné votre
police judiciaire elle est dans la main
de quelqu'un qui a les choses
départementales si on si on tire le si
on tire le raisonnement maintenant en
fait on est il y a deux pour nous il y a
deux niveaux différents niveau
départemental donc l'action
opérationnelle le régional qu'est-ce
qu'il fait le régional il met de la
cohérence la cohérence ça peut être la
délinquance itinérance je reviens sur ce
sujet là mais parfois quand vous voulez
avoir une action sont construites vous
êtes obligé de raisonner sur de l'Inter
départemental et vous avez une action
qui est menée par un paracommandant de
région mais c'est valable pour nous
enfin c'est valable pour plein de choses
je si je vais sur un question d'ordre
public par exemple
il y a quelques jours on a eu des
manifestations autour des bassines on
est à la jonction de trois départements
vous faites comment sur les trois
départements si vous n'avez pas
quelqu'un qui vient pour dire bon bah
écoutez les gars je vais prendre la
coordination de cette affaire là vous
faites comment vous avez trois chefs
différents sur une même action
c'est pas raisonnable mais c'est pareil
en polyjudiciaire la police judiciaire
c'est pas quelque chose d'abstrait c'est
quelque chose qui se qui se résonne qui
se comprend qui se construit quand vous
travaillez sur du trafic de déchets
pourquoi le trafic du déchet de déchets
s'arrêterait-il à un département
il va être au niveau régional et les
délinquants travaillent au niveau
régional voire national voire
internationale donc on voit bien qu'il y
a la place pour une action
départementale qui est l'action de
proximité opérationnelle mais que vous
avez besoin
au-dessus du département en tout cas
c'est notre vision des choses de
quelqu'un qui met de la cohérence qui va
être l'emploi maintenant le commandant
de région n'a pas vocation à être le
chef opérationnel de tous les
départements dans sa région d'abord je
suis pas sûr que ça plairait beaucoup au
préfet qui des départements limitrophes
pas forcément magistrats mais en
revanche je pense que un procureur
général trouve avantage à avoir en face
de lui à commandant de région qui
s'intéresse à la police judiciaire et
qui soit capable à un moment donné
d'avoir de donner des directives qui
soient cohérentes pour l'ensemble de la
gendarmerie
bien la parole à Monsieur Alain Marc
puis madame l'herbier puis monsieur
watte bled plus madame aribet merci
président mon Général merci pour cette
exposé très pédagogique qui finalement
nous renseignent bien sur ce qu'est la
police judiciaire à l'intérieur de la
gendarmerie moi j'avais une question sur
le recueil de renseignements il y a
quelques années de cela je m'étais déjà
inquiété d'ailleurs auprès auprès de
notre commandant de groupement il y a 10
ans 15 ans quand j'étais consciental et
député d'ailleurs sur le lien qui
s'était un petit peu distendu entre la
gendarmerie locale et la population on
voyait beaucoup moins les gendarmes sur
le terrain sans doute accaparer par les
procédures et il semblerait que depuis
quelques années alors les instructions
venant sans doute de vous-même que ce
soit inversé et qu'à nouveau nous ayons
des gendarmes auprès de la population
des élus aussi ce qui est extrêmement
important de façon à recueillir du
renseignement il me semble que c'était
ce qui faisait qui du jour la qualité de
la gendarmerie française je crois savoir
qu'en 2001 après les attentats les
Américains ont été venus d'ailleurs voir
comment il se faisait que nous ayons une
qualité de renseignement à Paris et
c'était surtout dû en partie d'une autre
rarement avec à la gendarmerie nationale
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous donnez des directives à vos
brigades pour qu'on aille de nouveau sur
le terrain
il m'a amervier
en général
comme mon collègue c'est avec grand
plaisir vous a écouté et on comprend
bien le cheminement de l'organisation
moi j'étais universitaire à l'île d'eux
à l'iegy de Lille 2 et on préparait les
concours de
commissaire et les concours de
d'officiers de gendarmerie les profils
étaient complètement différents il y
avait un engouement des deux côtés
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
l'ordre public
s'intéresse beaucoup les jeunes et il y
avait vraiment une une volonté de faire
partie de de ces de cette de ces deux
institutions
la seule chose la gendarmerie il y avait
le côté caserne qui au début pour un
jeune de 20 ans et se poser la question
s'ils allaient s'y plier s'il allait y
être bien
et le général Hébrard qui commandait le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais nous a fait visiter
Pontoise et on est on y retourné ici
avec avec la commission des lois c'était
remarquable ce qui s'y passait
remarquable il avait enquêté lui sur le
la mort de la princesse Diana il nous
avait expliqué tout le tout le parcours
de la police judiciaire à l'époque et
c'était extraordinaire je veux bien
croire que quand on voit
le
la possibilité de donner dans ce
cadre-là que
[Musique]
réformer la police pour que ça soit dans
le même état d'esprit je veux bien
croire que ça soit une volonté pour pour
aller dans le même sens alors c'est vrai
ce que disait notre président le
contact avec la population
est déterminant parce que vous repérez
les numéros les locaux repèrent les
numéros d'immatriculation les les choses
suspects les choses qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être
la police change plus à mon sens vous
allez me dire si c'est vrai si c'est
faux de territoire et donc ils ont
peut-être plus de difficultés aussi à
repérer tout ça
[Musique]
vous nous avez dit aussi que il y avait
mon collègue disait beaucoup de de
procédures la procédure judiciaire
demande beaucoup de temps
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a des
choses à améliorer de ce côté là malgré
tout
et enfin
j'aurais aimé savoir dans l'ensemble
est-ce que même en ayant
toute cette panoplie de police
judiciaire qui semble aller tout à fait
parfaitement est-ce que vous avez des
des points que vous pensez nécessaires
d'améliorer même dans la gendarmerie
pour le transposer éventuellement à la
police ceci tant qu'à faire pour
réformer autant prendre tout ce qu'il y
a bien tout ce qu'il y a de mieux merci
Monsieur
général pour vos réponses et surtout
nous en informer moi j'ai une double
question par rapport à l'évolution la
délinquance on est plus à l'époque du
braquage je vois très bien dit
maintenant on est aussi bir-attaque de
même pour la formation puisque vous
l'avez rappelé c'est un combat par
rapport à l'opinion moi je pose une
question simplement pour savoir quels
moyens vous avez par rapport à au
recrutement justement de personnes qui
sont très pointues parce qu'il faut pas
se le dire pour être à cœur il faut
avoir que des gens en face est-ce que
vous pouvez recruter je lui dis ça des
gens qui viennent de ce milieu
éventuellement pour vous donner
l'expertise des gens qui savent rentrer
dans les réseaux par derrière puisque on
dit la plupart des sans colle blanc on
voit bien ce que c'est que le raquette
rançon par Internet le vol de carte
bleue et quels moyens avez-vous est-ce
que vous débrouillez fortement cette ces
moyens là et en parallèle aussi
l'information puisque c'est une bataille
tous les jours on voit bien vous l'avez
rappelé que les fake news c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est courant pour
protéger vos hommes et surtout vos
réseaux
merci Madame Marie
vous avez répondu en répondant à Jérôme
du Rhin vous avez répondu aux questions
que je voulais vous poser j'ai envie de
vous poser une question mais je suis
certaine que vous ne pourrez pas y
répondre
non c'est parce que mais je vais la
poser quand même parce que c'est une
manière de de
synthétiser un petit peu aussi vous avez
parlé de de polyvalence mais la
polyvalence c'est pas le flou artistique
c'est à dire que même s'il y a
polyvalence chacun fait ce qu'il doit
faire au moment où il doit le faire
et pour avoir
bénéficier d'un stage d'immersion en
gendarmerie tout ce que vous avez dit je
le reconnais vraiment et c'est vraiment
ce que j'ai vécu entre
la dimension territoriale et puis la
dimension
recherche cyber et on retrouve
complètement à la fois cet appartenance
à une communauté et puis
en même temps chacun fait son son job au
moment où il doit le faire alors la
question que j'aurais envie de vous
poser c'est qu'en fait moi j'ai
l'impression et c'est là où je dis que
vous répondrez pas qu'on cherche à
à calquer un modèle qui marche dans la
gendarmerie à une autre culture qui
n'est pas la même culture et sur la et
qui ne peut pas marcher parce qu'on
n'est pas dans la même culture mais
comme vous avez dit que vous n'étiez pas
là pour parler de la police vous n'y
répondrai pas mais en tout cas nous
c'est quelque chose que qu'on doit qu'on
doit retenir et pour être sûr que vous
ne
que sans répondre à la question que je
viens de poser vous allez répondre à nos
données confirmation de cette analyse
quelqu'un vient de parler de du temps
nécessaire il ne vous est jamais arrivé
je suppose de renoncer à une enquête et
un pouvoir de police judiciaire au
prétexte que vous n'aviez pas les
effectifs en territorial parce que là on
touche en effet du doigt un des éléments
essentiels de des inquiétudes au niveau
de la police
monsieur Richard
merci Michel le Président Monsieur le
Major Général merci pour vos
informations je souhaiterais juste
rebondir sur la réponse que vous avez
faite à la question une des questions de
Jérôme Durand concernant
la dichotomie département région est-ce
que
le passage aux grandes régions
à constitué pour vous un avantage
à quantifier pour vous un avantage en
émission qui est la vôtre ou un
inconvénient si vous pouvez nous parler
si vous pouvez nous parler directement
ce serait encore mieux voilà
parce que j'ai naturellement des
informations
spécifiques à cet égard mais je ne vous
citerai pas quel
commandant de groupement m'a dit ça tout
particulièrement concernant la région
Grand Est je m'arrête là
merci Monsieur Richard madame la
Présidente à sacie merci monsieur le
Président je vais être très rapide merci
beaucoup monsieur en général pour votre
vos propos liminaires qui a été d'une
grande
clarté on apprend toujours moi j'ai une
simple question monsieur Darmanin a été
auditionné à l'Assemblée nationale et il
a réitéré en fait cette proposition qui
devrait trouver qui devait devrait être
concrétisés lors de la l'examen du
projet loi de finances qu'il y aurait
donc 905 950 effectifs supplémentaires
sortie d'école qui arriveront dans les
brigades territoriales de la gendarmerie
et donc il serait en mesure de créer 90
à 95 brigades de gendarmerie après
accord bien évidemment pour leur
implantation et les conditions de
travail alors il y a certains qui
proposent que c'est
brigades soient
installé là où elles ont été supprimer
puisqu'il y a eu des suppressions de de
brigade j'aimerais savoir qu'on regarde
de votre de votre connaissance bien
évidemment du terrain et de votre
expertise pensez-vous que ce serait la
bonne réponse vous qu'au regardez
l'évolution de la délinquance dans toute
sa dimension il serait peut-être
préférable de réfléchir à une
implantation autre que là où il y a eu
suppression de brigade
si même la présidence écoutez madame
vous avez la parole pour répondre à
l'ensemble des questions qui vous ont
été posées je regarde l'horloge pour
l'instant tout va bien
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
concernant donc
le gendarme départemental sont contacts
avec la population avec avec les élus
l'exercice du renseignement
je pense qu'on a pris on a pris un
virage
2015-2016 et en fait c'était assez
prémonitoire parce que le
directeur général de l'époque avait dit
il faut qu'on revienne au contact de la
population il y a un besoin de service
public dans nos territoires il y a trop
de distance et il faut qu'on priorise le
contact et j'ai trouvé ça prémonitoire
parce que trois ans après on avait le
gilets jaunes alors évidemment
je suis certainement pas
avoir la prétention de donner des
explications au mouvement des gilets
jaunes mais je pense que le contact ça
fait partie aussi des choses et des
éléments de réflexion et ça la
gendarmerie je crois a su l'anticiper
dans son territoire
et pour faire ça en fait à l'époque le
directeur général a dit moi
je veux pas qu'on compte les crimes les
délits les taux d'élucination parce que
les chiffres on peut toujours les
truander faire monter un taux
d'élucidation il y a aucun problème
n'importe quel commandant de brigade
sera le fait donc dès que vous donnez
des objectifs chiffrés vous installez
des comportements déviants et en fait la
population elle elle voit ce qui se
passe au coin de sa rue ou au poids de
sa porte donc il y a ceux qui se compte
et il y a ceux qui comptent et ceux qui
comptent c'est la réalité du travail que
vous faites auprès de la population là
où aussi nous avons je crois
[Musique]
faire marche arrière c'est que comme
beaucoup de d'institutions
d'administration nous avons été bercés
par le contrôle de gestion la
performance etc bon sauf que parfois ce
qui est le plus important dans ce que
fait un jour d'armes c'est justement ce
qui ne se peut pas se mesurer si vous
passez du temps au contact de la
population ça va se mesurer comment
statistiquement c'est pas un fait résolu
c'est pas si vous allez voir une
personne âgée au coin de la rue en
contact population pour la rassurer vous
luttez contre le sentiment d'insécurité
mais ça se traduit comment au point de
vue statistique et je j'affirme quand
gendarmerie il n'y a aucune directive en
matière statistique aucun objectif
chiffré qui soit donné aux unités en
revanche il y a une consigne qui essaie
d'augmenter la présence de voies
publiques et c'est également ce que le
ministre attend de nous donc il n'y a
pas la culture du chiffre
en gendarmerie on l'a eu il faut le
reconnaître il y a une quinzaine
d'années on a été dans ce dans ce dans
ce mouvement là mais je pense qu'on a eu
aussi la lucidité de se dire que ça nous
envoyer aussi dans le mur à certains
endroits et qu'au bout du compte de
toute façon le juge de paix c'est la
population c'est le sentiment
d'insécurité et moi je suis très heureux
que le ministre de l'Intérieur est
décédé de procéder à des sondages
populations dans le dans le cas des
objectifs de présence de voie publique
et de et de rassurer la de rassurer la
de rassurer la population donc voilà le
cheminement qu'on a fait c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile parce que sa
sœur a d'autres priorités je prends par
exemple les violences intra-familiales
aujourd'hui des dans nos brigades les
gendarmes passent un temps considérable
sur le traitement des violences
intra-fiales d'abord en intervention
mais ensuite dans le traitement de
l'affaire et alors vont me direz
heureusement mais on passe beaucoup plus
de temps qu'auparavant sur les enquêtes
de violence intra familiale violence
conjugue ils le font il y a pas de sujet
là-dessus simplement on voit bien que
d'un côté vous aimeriez que voir les
gendarmes dans la rue et de l'autre côté
ils sont derrière leur bureau parce que
il va falloir procéder à davantage
d'actes à davantage de comment dire et
apprendre davantage de temps donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que notre objectif
c'est le contact on veut libérer les
énergies et donc libérer du temps pour
le gendarme c'est pas facile mais le
meilleur service qu'on puisse le rendre
c'est de leur dire on a confiance en
vous on a confiance en vous et on sait
qu'une grande partie de ce que vous
faites n'est pas mesurable
sur le concernant alors
là on va dire la manière vous parler des
officiers de gendarmerie des
commissaires de des commissaires de
police
moi je me hazarderai pas à les comparer
mais je vais vous dire sur quoi je crois
parce que pour le coup j'ai un peu
participé il y a une dizaine d'années
nous nous considérons que l'officier de
gendarmerie c'est avant tout quelqu'un
qui a été éprouvé au plus près du
terrain et quelqu'un qui a été éprouvé
dès son premier poste en gendarmerie
quand vous sortez de Melun que vous
soyez université saint-cyrien Bac+5 ou
polytechnicien vous commencez dans une
brigade territoriale vous commandez une
brigade vous commandez à peloton de
gendarmerie mobile
alors après vous ferez peut-être des tas
d'autres choses mais vous commencez au
plus près du terrain et je pense que
c'est un très bon système on n'a pas
chez nous des cadres supérieurs qui
commencent dans une fonction de cadre
supérieur
et je pense que c'est vraiment à très
bon système on l'a instauré maintenant
il y a entre 10 un peu plus de un peu
plus de 10 ans mais je pense que ça nous
permet d'avoir de jeunes officiers qui
savent de quoi ils parlent et qui vont
pas être des personnalités un peu
étirées avec une conception
intellectualisée du métier mais des gens
quand vous vous êtes vous pardonnerez
l'expression mais quand vous êtes
coltiné le maire du coin qui est pas
content parce que il y a des incivilités
parce qu'il y a du bruit parce que si
parce que ça parce qu'il y a des
décharges publics et qui vous dit que
vous êtes jamais là où il faudrait bon
je veux dire ça apprend la vie et nous
on veut que nos jeunes officiers et nos
jeunes officiels soient éprouvés sur le
terrain au contact et ça pour nous c'est
essentiel et on pense également que
notre métier est un métier de
commandement et que le commandement
s'est fait pour
c'est fait aussi pour prendre des
décisions c'est fait aussi pour être
capable de défendre la boutique y
compris par rapport à les autorités
concernant des possibilités de
simplifier et d'aider les enquêteurs oui
on a des on a des projets une des
questions ce serait de pouvoir davantage
oraliser la procédure c'est-à-dire
d'avoir des systèmes de retranscription
automatique qui nous permettraient de
gagner du temps il y a la procédure
pénale numérique qui est en train d'être
déployée bon c'est on en est au début
mais lorsqu'on aura déployé complètement
la procédure pénale numérique on va
gagner du temps puisque les toutes les
procédures seront dématérialisées donc
au lieu de d'avoir de faire des
photocopies de procédure etc bon je
pense qu'on il y a des choses si vous
voulez le problème c'est qu'on a des
choses contradictoires c'est à dire on
fait à la fois beaucoup pour simplifier
mais en même temps est toujours pour des
raisons très nobles on fait beaucoup
pour compliquer bon c'est le c'est une
lutte
permanente sur les points d'expertise de
la police nation bien évidemment on a
beaucoup à apprendre de nos de nos
camarades et partenaires de la police
nationale ils ont des comment dire des
pôles d'expertise et quand vous voyez le
travail que fait par exemple la DGSI en
matière de en matière de terrorisme je
pense qu'elle a déjà ici il y a des
expertises rares et nous on est très
contents et très heureux de travailler
en appui et dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme la prévention du terrorisme
on prend notre part qui est la détectée
des signaux faibles renseignement la
population mais on voit aussi qu'on a
des gens qui sont qui connaissent
parfaitement leur métier quand on
travaille sur la PAF en matière
d'immigration régulière on fait notre
part du travail mais on a aussi besoin
de travailler avec des unités
spécialisées donc
et puis il y a des projets communs il y
a par exemple un projet sur lequel on
est en réflexion avec
la DGPN c'est celui de la vidéo plainte
il faut y réfléchir il faut y réfléchir
la vision plante parce que et nous en
zone gendarmerie ça nous intéresse parce
qu'on a des espaces à couvrir et que
lorsque vous avez quelqu'un qui doit
faire 20 ou 30 km pour aller à la
brigade pour déposer plainte bon deux
solutions soit c'est le gendarme qui
vient vers elle ce que nous faisons et
nous étions de faire de plus en plus
avec les solutions de mobilité ou alors
vous encourager le développement de la
visioplinte pour simplifier la vie des
Français évidemment pour ce qui relève
des atteintes au bien etc sera beaucoup
plus compliqué pour tout ce qui est des
atteintes aux personnes donc on a aussi
des projets communs et d'ailleurs le la
loi d'orientation
pour le ministère pour la le ministère
d'intérieur prévoit qui est une agence
du numérique qui sera commune aux forces
de sécurité donc on est bien sur des
voilà sur un travail
conjoint sur le recrutement d'experts
plusieurs choses d'abord ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est d'une grande
souplesse de gestion alors ça c'est là
je crois que c'est la toute la
gendarmerie c'est qu'en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
le statut militaire permet beaucoup de
souplesse par rapport je pense à la
gestion des personnels civiles nous on
peut recruter on a des officiers qui
sortent des grandes écoles militaires
mais on a aussi des gendarmes qui
restent chez nous tout en devenant
expert mais on est aussi capable d'aller
chercher des officiers recrutés sur
titre au regard de leur diplôme et on
est aussi capable de recruter des
officiers sous-contrat qui viennent chez
nous pour une période déterminée et en
fait on a des gens qui peuvent être
intéressés à un moment donné dans leur
parcours dans une entreprise privée pour
se dire moi pendant trois quatre ans je
vais acquérir des une expertise en
matière de crypto monnaie ou autre je
vais faire des choses intéressantes etc
donc on est capable de recruter de
fidéliser et la création du commandement
cyber de la gendarmerie obéit à cette
logique parce que là le centre de
gravité comme le disent les militaires
le centre de gravité de la lutte contre
la cybercriminalité c'est la compétence
en ressources humaines et nous avons
créé le commandement cyber pour mettre
dans la même main l'opérationnelle les
moyens la recherche mais aussi la
gestion d'affiliaire de la filière
métier ça c'est la logique du
commandement du commandant cybel sur
notre comparaison avec le modèle police
évidemment je vous avais parfaitement
raison il y a des terrains sur lesquels
que je me sur lesquels je me hazarderai
pas aller mais je vais quand même vous
dire les deux les deux à trois choses
dans lesquelles on croit et vous lirez
ma réponse en creux nous croyons nous
croyons en une gendarmerie qui soit
hiérarchisée structurée et vertébrés
c'est-à-dire que quand vous avez deux
gendarmes quelque part il y en a un qui
commande l'autre c'est un principe de
base mais si vous ne le suivez pas à un
moment donné c'est l'irresponsabilité
l'irresponsabilités collectives donc
chez nous il y a toujours
qui est là pour dire c'est moi le
responsable de cette affaire là donc ça
ça nous paraît ça nous parait essentiel
ensuite sur la comment faire quand on a
des effectifs des objectifs et que tout
ça est limité et qu'on sait pas quelle
priorité accordée nous nous essayons de
travailler en devis judiciaire disant
voilà si on s'engage sur telle chose
ça va coûter tant d'effectif et ça va
nécessiter tant de moyens on y va où on
y va pas comment on priorise et c'est là
que le chef hiérarchique a un rôle à
jouer avec le magistrat après infini
c'est le magistrat qui décide et c'est
lui qui commande mais on a besoin de
faire ce devis judiciaire alors on en
est pas là où en sont notamment les
Britanniques qui en gros vont dire bon
moi je me je travaille là-dessus parce
que c'est ce qui intéresse la population
et le reste je le mets j'en sais pas une
priorité mais il faut qu'on ait ce
besoin de vie judiciaire si vous voulez
si on a une affaire qui mobilise et ça
m'est arrivé d'avoir une affaire qui
pendant 18 mois va mobiliser 10
enquêteurs pour au bout du compte un
résultat pénal qui sera très faible vous
dites que les moyens de l'État et de la
et du pays ont pas forcément été
employés au mieux donc il y a besoin de
travailler aussi en devis judiciaire
pour dire voilà voilà le temps qu'on va
y consacrer les effectifs et les moyens
qu'on va consacrer est-ce qu'au bout du
compte on aura aidé à la sécurité de la
de nos concitoyens
sur le passage aux grandes régions alors
là l'Alsacien que je suis
va voir va avoir beaucoup de mal à
beaucoup de mal à comment dire à
répondre bon plus j'irai plus plus
sincèrement
nous nous étions encore calés sur les
R22 les 22 les 22 régions à un moment
donné on se retrouve dans des régions où
on a plus de correspondant au niveau des
préfets de région on se retrouve avec 22
états majors de région bon
alors que on a besoin de renforcer nos
unités de terrain c'est la logique qui a
prévalu pour la gendarmerie pour dire on
va passer au R13 et donc la région Grand
Est on va faire un commandant de région
et et
il y a quand le groupe alors là où je
suis relativement à l'aise pour pour
parler c'est que j'ai été à la fois
commandant de groupement du Bas-Rhin
j'ai eu cette honneur de 2006 à 2008 et
puis j'ai été aussi commandant de la
région Grand Est il y a très récemment
j'ai quitté mes fonctions en 2019 je
pense que c'est une bonne réforme pour
le service que nous rendons la
population pourquoi parce que le
Bas-Rhin a retrouvé un commandant de
groupement de plein exercice et Dieu
sait si dans le Bas-Rhin il y a
suffisamment de travail pour être
totalement polarisé là-dessus et on a
commandé région Grand Est à la charge
justement de coordonner les moyens dès
lors qu'on est sur des phénomènes qui
dépassent les frontières d'un
département donc moi j'en ai une vision
plutôt positive de comment dire de cette
réforme je pense qu'il a économisé un
peu de moyens en état-major et qu'il a
recentré des commandants de groupement
sur les vous savez le je pense que dans
le Bas-Rhin le commandant de groupement
qui était également commandant de région
depuis 10 ans avait du mal avait du mal
à concilier les deux c'est ce que j'ai
cru ce que j'ai cru apercevoir et en ce
qui concerne les effectifs les brigades
et la manière dont ça va se passer alors
d'abord c'est en concertation avec les
élus et il est demandé à chaque préfère
en associant le corps en groupement de
réunir les maires concernés de poser à
diagnostic sur l'organisation l'activité
de la Gendarmerie et de là dans déduire
les endroits où la création d'unité
pourrait être profitable donc il s'agit
pas de recréer des unités là elles ont
été dissoutes il s'agit de créer des
unités là où on considère qu'il y a
qu'il y a un manque voilà ça c'est le
c'est la logique et après on est très
souple dans le type d'unité dans le type
d'unité créée
[Musique]
bien merci beaucoup mon général pour
l'ensemble de précisions que vous avez
apportées
nous allons donc terminer cette audition
et reprendre dans quelques minutes avec
l'audition du garde des sceaux en tout
et en tous les cas cela je crois a
permis d'éclairer tout le monde sur le
fonctionnement de la gendarmerie que
l'on parfois prête en connaître que
souvent on ne connaît pas très bien et
au moins aujourd'hui les choses sont
claires et les enjeux sont également
bien marqués en tout cas merci pour vos
propos et toutes les précisions que vous
nous avez apporté merci à vous merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci de
votre écoute